I'm gonna [__] go on Instagram and
say oh a bunch of blue check mark
[__] guys are liking my [__] I'm like
wow that's amazing and then I go find
out that everyone bought them
[Music]
and why do I even give a [__] about that
dude hey what's up hey hey blue check
hey what you doing having 648 followers
getting verified
Jordan
what you doing being a [__] licensed
massage therapist
get park it helps business okay dude you
know what helps business business
laughs
I mean hey you know what else can
business hey you know it helps business
business dude okay
not changing the color next to your name
right
you're buying blue check marks for 11 or
15 a month I don't know how much it is
whatever how much it is it's too much
and I put the freaking clip on uh
Instagram dude the thing went dummy
viral and everyone's [__] getting mad
at me also loving it
so I have a question for the people who
buy the verification on Instagram
foreign
now what
you know you you buy the blue check mark
okay
and then you have it
and then what
your life's the same
yeah
you have it that's great you paid for it
and your life's the same
right
it's not different
at all it's not different at all
you wake up you're still you
you do the same thing
yeah so it's like what are you what are
you doing
right
they got you
you're a sucker
you're a soccer
your life's the sad dude I'm gonna tell
you how the [__] it is that's it dude
I've got nothing left I will tell you
how it is
if you buy a blue check mark maybe maybe
if you're something like
a photographer
or if you're
a plastic surgeon
okay
but hey
are you Johnny
don't get hey are you Bill
a guy
keep the eleven dollars hey
hey
are you Nicole hey Nikki
keep the eleven dollars
hey are you Hank
hey hey
Lisa keep it
we're good
you helping your business ah
I mean it's just so ridiculous these
people buying you kudas man Instagram it
made so much money off the [__] I want I
want to buy I want to buy I'm gonna I'm
paying to have my blue check mark
removed
bro here's what they should do they
should make everyone buy this is so
gangster and if I was this is why I
don't run the [__] this is legit why I
will never be as big as I possibly can
because I would do [__] like this if I
was this is why I'll never be in charge
of anything dude if I was Instagram or
Facebook or whatever the [__] it is Mark
Zuckerberg Zuckerberg Zuckerberg
I would get everyone to buy the
Instagram and then whoever bought the
Instagrams
I would one day change them all green
and they were all be they would all be
exposed so you got licensed massage
therapists just like this
oh no
all of a sudden Lisa's just at the
sorority house just like oh wait what
I don't understand it
I get it though we all want to be
accepted right everyone wants their
extra [__]
their share I don't know
I don't know we all search for
validation in certain ways
when I did it through having sex okay
I'm good all good
deep dive into my psyche oh good oh good
crazy congratulations
[Music]